this place is so nice this is supposed
to be one of the best French places in
town hmm I did not realize that you were
so cultured you're sweet
my French is pretty good so I can order
for both of us oh sure
welcome to Chez dellamonte on Ventura I
am your waiter for this evening my name
is jean-luc de l'épée I will notes but
you may call me Jean Moses on will be on
any questions about anything at all I'm
more than happy to assist you John I got
it
merci beaucoup que bien well our first
special tonight is our Poisson du jour
is a Loup de mer bleue of a song served
with a puny avert du cochon de permit
that is served on a bed of gendarme -
Felisa Appa and also serve a Lumina
crush and souffle petit theatre du Pont
Grenier YUM our soup today is the
Palermo salt with just a dash of
shamballa
and served with melted pistol Tasha back
traphil so yeah our other seafood today
we have a very nice feeling from Hong
Kong the poor serve us from the good
source of alien visitor it is served
with the side of Colombo Fantoni de la
mota
do God from here Cologne sauce oh I'm so
glad you said that I was about to say
the same man getting the flan thump
uncle aunt dumpty plump it's a valve
with the I'm sorry is the pinnacle ET de
Paseo boom law and a heavy falls on
thought sauce oh no no no it's more like
a caution to come to come to Vaughn
sauce Oh what do you think I'm I'm gonna
defer to him on this one because he
knows this stuff away better than I do
it's miss you
yeah well we'll have the song and what's
had it through different was awesome
there's been nice knowing you have a
lovely dinner
you